bah
et
là je veux ce côté là c'est ce coin là
que j'ai été bousculé et ça m'a fait ça
m'a fait vraiment mal donc je ne savais
pas comment réagir
j'essaye d'y assister quand je vous ai
dit trois trois fois non pas de volume
nous n'ont pas voulu faire la rentrée
mais je suis rentré chez moi je me suis
senti humilié ça fait mal moi c'est ce
que j'ai ressenti
je me suis sentie curie dans ma chair
je pleurais au fond de mon coeur
voilà
c'est ma femme qui m'a vu la vidéo je
sais pas si la vie en premier mais c'est
elle qui m'a appelé et en premier madiba
oui qu'est ce qui est arrivé pour 4 nous
appartient touche dit que les gouttes et
déjà j'ai été jetée mal donc tu couvres
ce n'était pas facile pour le dire vos
enfants de l'éveil en train de se faire
mouche qui transfère agressé par
d'autres personnes qui ne sont pas
donnés l'amp ce n'est pas facile pour
eux donc ils vont dire qu'elle est à
temps commence à 5 e
les blancs sont méchant parlement donc
du coup j'étais essaie de leur faire
comprendre voilà c'est parti les banques
concernées font c'est pas aussi tous les
horizons
voilà
voilà ça c'est juste une petite famille
gens qui sont là
qu'ils sont méchants et que font du mal
aux gens ne sont pas tous jeu des
comparaisons vous partez à l'école vos
yeux votre m'interessent et déjanté avec
vos amis qui sont allés besson junte
avec vous
vous frappez vous à crespin donc j'étais
obligé de faire ce genre de thérapie par
rapport à mes enfants pour qu'ils
acceptent qu'ils comprennent que la vie
c'est pas que duras
j'ai du mal à réaliser que c'était là il
ya cinq ans
mais bon c'est comme ça comme j'ai dit
il faut toujours se battre faut pas se
laisser faire la lutte rendu
il y aura des indécis comme ça qui sont
là qui vont nous empêcher de vivre
nous on sera là pour les condamner ce
qui a été fait par la justice française
ce que je fais actuellement je m'occupe
de francs qui sont défavorisés dans le
monde donc c'est quoi ce courant qui
pérennise abus
sa décollecte faire des grands
événements depuis des pubs en histoire
jusqu'à maintenant je suis concentré que
ces deux choses la solidarité pour
l'humanité
et mon travail franchement ça m'a aidé
beaucoup à surmonter beaucoup
d'histoires par rapport à ça et je
commence à oublier mais bon va là on
essaie quand même de se battre pour que
ce genre de choses ça plus trop que ça
se reproduise plus
[Musique]